thousands of firefighters are trying to
stop a quickly growing wildfire near
Yosemite National Park in California the
dead wildfire has burned more than forty
eight thousand acres that is a larger
area than Washington DC to put that in
perspective the fire has destroyed 29
buildings and threatens 1,500 more it is
only seven percent contained this is
just one of dozens of wildfires burning
across the West
Mireya Villarreal is in Mariposa
California with the devastation Maria
good morning good morning officials are
calling this fire extreme and aggressive
it hollowed out this home right here
pretty quickly leaving behind a just
small portion of the frame in nearly two
days this fire doubled in size and
forced the evacuation of thousands of
homes more than 3,000 firefighters from
across California are racing to battle
the Detwiler fire where towering flames
and thick smoke are consuming the
state's historic Gold Country it's dry
at night as almost as much as it before
the game and so when you have the same
burning conditions all the way 24 hours
a day it's really hard to get inside
from the air nearly two dozen air
tankers and helicopters are shuttling
water and retardant over the fierce
flames dry shifting winds have made them
difficult to predict on the ground crews
are hiking through steep rugged terrain
building fire lines to try and control
the fast-moving blaze one way they are
fighting these fires is by creating this
line of vegetation right here with
bulldozers it's a way to keep the fire
from getting any closer to the road and
to people's properties almost 5,000
people are under an evacuation order
including the entire town of Mariposa
the fire came within less than a mile of
turning Anthony Scoggins home into ash
there was hotshot crews behind my
property line cutting anything they can
to keep the fire from coming in
nearby Yosemite Park is still open right
now but a number of power lines were
taken down by the fire during peak
tourist season right now there are about
six thousand firefighters battling
blazes all around California we're
looking at about a dozen fires right now
Nora all right Maria thank you